[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
hey look at me
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
folks
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
tell me
you know
all right
[Music]
yes
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
come on
[Applause]
um
um
come back
[Music]
uh
my friends
[Music]
and radio
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
gives us
[Music]
[Music]
um
freedom foreign
all the things
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
though
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
programs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we'd like to
welcome you to tonight's
rally with donald j trump
jr
[Applause]
peterbilt here in sparks
he is also the owner of silver state's
trucking company he's been an
outstanding host for
succeeding for tonight's events
supporting the president's re-election
please welcome the stage
the owner and host mr
john phillips
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
with the california swamp uh
and walkers walking two and a half miles
so i hosted a party to go back to find
out where
where he where he lived i had the rick
revellio
from western supply you know rick good
republican
uh paulinas president of the nevada
trucking association
uh also a great fundraiser and
represents as well
in carson city and adam laxalt so
we go back we love adam i love adam but
i i really
i we kicked off his gubernatorial here
two years ago but i really didn't know
him that well
so we spent four days at the trump tower
in chicago
and then we went down to the notre dame
usc football game
so and i got a chance to see where my
dad lived it was in welsh hall
which is now what girl's doing so i
it was at all boys school when he went
back to 1933.
but anyway talking to adam i said adam
tell me what you know
history behind you we all know about his
family i mean uh you know the pioneers
in the state and
i've done so many things but uh anyway
he
uh he said i went to georgetown
undergraduate
and uh got a law degree and he said
there were 600
students and there were 12 conservatives
so i think that's where he got his
debating
skills in over the years he served two
terms
in afghanistan and um he
um we all know ron desantis the uh
the governor okay great guy uh but
anyway that was
that was uh adam's uh roommate uh for a
period of time and that's how they
became
really um really good friends so
he met his uh his wife back there at uh
i think it was
uh in at georgetown it could have been
the uh
the newman center i'm not sure quite all
what took place but
the other thing he told me that um
at the naval academy
they would choose two professors
uh to come in and teach a class
there were 600 applicants adam laxalt
was the first one chosen
out of two so i i you know and this
he's one of the finest young men i i
think i've ever met
and you were in minden i think uh
the president talked uh very uh um
to him and said hey help us out with the
harvesting and the voter fraud and all
the other crazy things that are going on
so
uh again welcome um it's a pleasure to
have you here
and uh i know we all we we need
everybody's support this is gonna be a
tough one kids all right
thank you ladies and gentlemen
mr john phillips our host this evening
give it a big round of applause
if we could take an attitude of prayer
i'd like to call to the podium
pastor and former state senator mr
maurice washington
please
boy this is exciting whoa this is really
loud it's exciting to be here tonight
and um
i tell you what i am more and more
pumped up i don't know about you but i
can't wait to vote
skip the mail-in ballots i'm going to
show up in person i'm going to make sure
my ballot counts
listen if you would just buy your heads
with me in a word of prayer we want to
honor those men and women that
serve in our law enforcement we want to
honor those men and women
that serve in the armed forces we want
to thank them for their services and
their family members
for supporting them so let's just pray
father god we really want to say thank
you to you
we give you all praise honor and glory
surely above you there is no other
beside you there is no other
you are god and god all by yourself god
we pray for
the success of this great country we
understand that we're at a pivotal point
we're at a season that only you can
guide the affairs of men
and i would pray oh god that you would
just bless your manservant
as you told esther god there's a time
that men need to rise up and accept the
calling and
our great president has accepted that
calling and now we pray that you put
your hands upon him the mantle of god is
upon him
as he leads this great nation those men
and women o god that are going for
public service offices we pray that you
would bless them too
pray that you bless this gathering bless
our families and keep them in the sin of
your divine will
do you be the glory and the honor and we
thank you for
our savior our lord jesus christ
amen
pastor maurice washington ladies and
gentlemen
next up to the stand honoring our
country i'd like to introduce the
longest serving state republican
chairman in the
united states of america the chairman of
the nevada republican party
mr michael mcdonald
are we doing northern nevada
make washoe really red let's make nevada
red
i was talking to my buddy robert i told
him in the back he said take a little
leisure because
we want to hear something from you so
robert this is for you man i appreciate
you
thank you i want you to think back
ladies and gentlemen
think back where you were these last
couple months
when the legislature decided they wanted
to steal your vote
think back when the legislature the
democrats
decided in the middle of the night to
change the law with less than 100 days
to mail in ballots not only to do that
they decided to take out the law that
was a felony
and just mail it down to a misdemeanor
so you can't tell me they're not
stacking the deck
we had a great protest and i saw a lot
of you we were together
in carson city when that went through we
were there when they had the pet the
protest against the police
a lot of you stood we stood shoulder to
shoulder about this
and i told you on the steps of carson
city
on the steps of the capitol mark my
words
governor sislek when about a
week out is going to drop the lower the
base
so he can get everybody out to vote so
why in the world would they change and
take your ballots
because they cannot beat you they cannot
win if we go toe to toe
many of you have come stole shoulder
shutter for donald trump to make sure
our assembly and our senators get
reelected and elect new ones
so we turn nevada red think about that
if they can't beat you they have to
change the entire laws
so they can cheat now if they're not
worried about cheating
why not play it straight up ladies and
gentlemen you've come together
you've united around donald trump when
we had the peaceful protest in
nevada the one of many peaceful
protesting men in nevada
give yourself a round of applause
because that was the largest
peaceful protest in the nation
now we looked at it this way we want to
be able to say our first amendment
rights
we do we hold that sacred we don't want
any governor
take away our rights we don't want to
let any legislature
take away our rights you have to send
the message
this campaign isn't about donald trump
this campaign's about you
you think they're coming after donald
trump no donald trump's standing in the
way
just to make sure they can't get to you
that man needs your help
he needs his family needs your help
if you watched the debate last night
did you watch the debate last night
our president's a pit bull
he came out the gate right and way to
have his voices heard
because you know why he cannot get a
fair shake
he wasn't debating just zoe biden he was
debating wallace and biden
why is he so tuned up well if you watch
the news today
you saw james comey couldn't answer
questions
there was a collusion they have done
everything they can
to make sure this man does not get
reelected they've indicted people with
them
they've gone over to hurt his family
they've made up these hoax russian lies
they were trying to impeach him when
this pandemic came in and tried to
handcuff him when he was trying to save
america
then he stopped the border coming in and
what do they do
they start calling a racist a xenophobe
no he's an american first man give me
some of that
the time now is to never take anything
lightly
i'm begging you guys this is all your
campaign
this is all of us it's all
responsibility i may be chair of the
republican party
and i have some of our officers here we
work day to day but this
is all of our campaign this isn't about
one person leading the party
this is your party and if you're
independent
and you're here today please i need you
to put everything aside
and get out for vote for donald trump if
you're a walk away democrat
i thank you i welcome you get out and
vote for donald trump but i need you to
get your neighbors
i want you to grab the neighbors i want
you to grab the store clerk your
babysitter the man who cuts your yard
anybody you can imagine make sure
they're registered and you drag them to
the polls
if your neighbors cannot make it down
they're elderly you help them out
you help hey the democrats open the door
so you help them out with the ballots
you take their ballots you take it over
to the campaign office
in washoe it'll get to the register
i guarantee it we put this up
if you have time to volunteer to be a
poll watcher
stop by the campaign office the donald
trump campaign office
and sign up to help watch polls we have
attorneys that have signed up but we are
going to put
common people like me and like you to
make sure
they don't steal our ballots to make
sure they don't steal our votes
we need to hear from you the silent
majority needs to arise one more time
never let anybody steal from you never
let them disrespect our veterans
and our police officers that are here
today
thank you for your service
i want to give a shout out to the mayor
and city council sparks
they tried to stop this peaceful protest
this is my fourth
i intend to have a lot more and i want
all you to show up
ladies and gentlemen that cannot silence
our voices this is a fight for american
freedom
this is a fight for democracy
think about that when you're saying this
pledge take those words to heart
many of us have family members that
didn't make it back from wars
nothing is more important than to
remember why we're all standing together
and defending freedom but the problem is
we're defending freedom
against our own people we need to send a
message
to this man as the right leader that
donald trump will
lead us out of the darkness into the
light out of this pandemic
but more importantly you show his family
love when he gets here because i brag
about you all the time
i brag about nevada like you've never
ever seen
so god bless you let's hey what do we
say let's respect this huh
everyone please join me in the pledge of
allegiance
please rise i pledge allegiance
to the flag the united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible
with liberty and justice for all god
bless you ray
god bless you let's take this
state party chairman michael mcdonald
ladies and gentlemen
next i'd like to call up to the podium
your state trump
co-chairman mr adam laxall
[Music]
all right everybody how we doing out
there
are we motivated
all right well we had a little debate
last night right did everybody watch it
and so predictably the pundits are
attacking the president
and you know look it's pretty clear
there's no question
that the the president wasn't soft
during the debate and he wasn't kind and
cuddly
we have a warrior in this president
right
the voters got to see a warrior
president that has fought for us
for three and a half years every single
day under siege
and what they can see on the other guy a
hundred-year-old
career politician bumbling through his
answers
all right
now what else did we get out of the
debate
we got something that
you really you really can't put into
numbers yet
and that is the media simply
will not cover the other side of the
story
and the president knows that which is
why he took some of these
things that nobody's hearing about
directly to the american people
so what did he take first how about
hunter biden
we're clapping for hunter biden
so look i think we all agree
families in general should be off limits
in politics
but should families be off limits if
your father is
not a former politician the sitting vice
president of the united states
these things the president mentioned
last night occurred while his father was
the vice president united states
the 3.5 million dollars from the russian
billionaire
the millions of dollars from the chinese
for this investment company we all know
by now he had no experience in any of
this stuff
and yet he made hundreds of thousands
probably millions and millions of
dollars
while his father was a sitting vice
president how many of you think that is
news
it's your job to continue to spread the
word and i just saw on twitter some good
news
searches for hunter biden are now up
tenfold
in google as they should be
and this is what trump knows that the
media and all the pundits still don't
understand
what else did he get out there yesterday
well we had the most
bombshell news drop yesterday afternoon
you had the director of national
intelligence
declassify this one page
letter that showed very clearly
that the hillary clinton campaign worked
with
the russians to set up
the russia collusion hoax what else was
in there
it said that they met with obama
and brennan if you haven't heard that
i'm sure you're just
shocked when i read it i sat for 30
minutes
speechless that is how far
they went to not just defeat the
president this is about
them holding power and they will do or
say whatever it takes
to hold power and that turned into
the russia collusion investigation the
molar probe
all of these unbelievable things that
unfortunately
the media just did not cover that
bombshell news
but tens of millions of americans heard
about it last night
what else did he cover well
he covered voter fraud and you guys all
hear it
anytime you watch the news or you read
an article
the media media dutifully fact checks
and says there's no such thing as voter
fraud everybody see that
the reality is of course there's voter
fraud there's voter fraud all over this
country
just this week you had the video about
the ballot harvester
selling are getting paid for harvesting
ballots in minnesota
you had a hundred thousand ballots go
out in new york
and they sent it to they had the wrong
name in the return address so some of
the
the fraud that we're talking about is
malicious intentional fraud
some of the fraud is just knowing that
there's no way to change an entire
voting system
and get it right how many of you would
change
your entire company or your entire
business
with less than 90 days to go of
something that's incredibly important
nobody here would do that but we know
the media
just simply will not report those facts
when the president got on this issue i
can tell you
that as we traveled the state in the in
the trump bus
nevada's all over this state are onto it
they're following it and they're
concerned about it
and we have the president to thank for
raising the attention of this incredibly
important issue
how about law and order
you know as the former attorney general
i am just shocked and appalled
that the leaders in this state the
governor the attorney general
and all of the democratic leadership
when law enforcement needed them most
they didn't stand with them they went
into a special session to
handcuff our law enforcement
and i remember distinctly
and many of you probably remember after
the october one shooting
these same democrat elected stood with
law enforcement
and said our law enforcement is the best
around what changed from 2017 to today
but we know that our law enforcement
didn't somehow become
racist and that they didn't become more
systemically racist
i'll tell you what changed politics
changed
it became unpopular for them to stand
with
the police with their base
and the president pressed and pressed
that issue
and he got the vice president to say
antifa is just an idea does anybody here
think antifa is just an
idea i think not
what else did he get the president the
vice president to do
he said joe tell me a single law
enforcement agency in all of america
that is supporting you
in all of america and he couldn't come
up with one
why because even police unions in las
vegas that have
never supported republicans they're
supporting republicans this year
because they know better
so i encourage you and look you guys may
not need encouraging but as you see
the pundits and you see the national
polls that continue to do what they did
in
16 which is say the president's down and
the race is over they're doing that for
a reason
they're suppressing the vote they're
trying to make all of you feel like it's
over
well we all know it's not over right
when we did the minden rally just a week
ago on
24 hours notice we had almost 30
000 people a sea of humanity show up
for president donald trump
millions and millions of people love
this guy and what do they love most
about him
i believe because he is a fighter
and people know we need a fighter now
more than ever
they're tired of republicans that will
not fight back
they're tired of the establishment they
want somebody that's going to get in
there and just slug away
for all of you and all of us
so i leave you with the final call to
action
it's up to you we need to go push
till the end you need to convince that
swing voter
because they're not going to hear it
from the media you need to convince the
voter this president has done more in
three and a half years than joe biden
has done
in 47 years right
and if they don't like his personality
you need to talk them through that
this isn't a personality contest this is
about results
promises made and promises kept can i
count on you for that
35 days we need to add nevada
to the roll call of states everybody
remember in 2016 where you were
trump had no chance of winning in fact i
think it was like 95
chance that hillary was gonna gonna win
and in came
florida in came pennsylvania
in came ohio and all of us were like
it's happening america has risen up
and they're going to put donald trump in
the white house are we going to put him
in the white house again
let's add nevada to the roll call of
states and let's win this
for donald j trump thank you
[Music]
mr adam lexo ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
[Music]
now
you cannot change
[Music]
you cannot change
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
we
[Music]
please don't take me
[Music]
i stay with you
[Music]
[Music]
things
[Music]
never changed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
lord i can't change
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
bye
[Music]
uh
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yellow man
come to me
[Music]
[Music]
i'm
oh
[Music]
do this
[Music]
[Music]
look
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
driving down the street today
i saw a sign for lemonade
they were the cutest kids i'd ever
seen in this front yard
as they handed me my glass
smiling thinking to myself
man what a picture perfect postcard this
wouldn't make of america
it's
[Music]
[Music]
one nation under god
it's american
[Music]
door apart
[Music]
myself i'm so glad that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
it's a kid with a chance it's a rock and
roll band it's a farmer cutting hay
it's a big flat fly and a summer winter
falling
[Music]
it's american
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
school bus driver
[Music]
is
i wanna keep dreams
[Music]
my
[Music]
red white and blue
[Music]
we all get a chance to dance
i'm going down
all they want is everything
she came out here to be an actress
[Music]
they could happen
[Music]
oh
everybody gets to dance
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as big as we want to get a chance to
[Music]
dance
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we're just a few
minutes away for the arrival
of kimberly guilfoyle and mr donald
trump
jr
again they'll be arriving shortly
we need a fired up crowd here in
northern nevada so i need that from you
[Music]
folks
[Music]
[Music]
it says
[Music]
[Music]
america
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
he's
[Music]
[Music]
is
made in america
[Applause]
being in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the story that my daddy tells
religiously
like clockwork every time he sees an
opening
in a conversation
[Music]
about the way things used to be
i just roll my eyes and make a beeline
for the door
i'd always end up starry-eyed
cross-legged on the floor
hanging
[Music]
it was harder times longer days
five-mile school up field
of course that was back before the war
yeah your uncle and i
made quite a pair flying that fifteens
through hostile earth
he went down but they missed me by
he'd always stop right there and say
that's something
[Music]
that's something to be proud of
son graduating college that was mama's
dream
and i was on my way to anywhere else
when i turned 18.
when you got a fast car
you think you got everything
[Music]
i learned quick those gtos don't run on
faith
but i ended up broken down in some town
northern valley
working maximum lives
for minimum wage
well i fell in love next thing i know
babies came the car got slow
sure do you miss that old hot rod super
saiyan gaston
foreign
said let me tell you right now
[Music]
love
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just look out like a small
[Music]
to be proud
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
oh
yes
take it easy baby
is
it easy
foreign
oh
maybe they
i can't remember
touched me
is
do you have faith in god
can you teach me how to dance
carnation and a pickup truck but i
knew the day
i started
that i oh
when the jesters
oh and while the king was looking down
the justice stolen
is
whiskey
the birthday
on the sidelines
the marching band
do you know the day
this is
a generation
is
right
he was singing
this would be the day that i died
the children
today
when they were singing
oh
singing this
so
from the city
uh
in the heavens
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
but i don't know who i
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
themselves
[Music]
[Music]
millionaires
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
me
every man wants to be
in the morning
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
is
man he likes to be the leader
all right
[Music]
my
[Music]
uh
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
freedom
[Music]
play hey
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
me
[Music]
you're always on the run now
boys
you really don't remember
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
but you really don't remember
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
i am
thank you
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
somebody
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
president of the united states
donald j trump men who died
who gave
[Music]
i love me land
god bless the usa
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
[Music]
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's
[Music]
no doubt
[Music]
god
[Music]
who died to you
and defend her still today
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody hello duluth got larger
oh thank you 34 days from now we're
going to win minnesota we're going to go
and win four more beautiful years in the
white house and do more than anybody's
ever done before from the white house
we're looking to set records i really
enjoyed
last night's debate with sleepy joe
i brought those hats out here because
minnesota's a little on the windy side
and like a genius i sent them all out
i'm getting blown to faces and that's
fine
that's okay i love it i love you to have
whatever we have we have it together
that i can tell you
the verdict is in and they say that we
we all of us won big last night
[Music]
and i don't know did you hear about this
in the history of cable television had
the highest ratings of any show in the
history of gabriel television
and it had the second highest ratings of
overall television
in the history of television does
anybody know what was first like mash
or something i guess smash no they had
the final episode of mesh
and uh i don't know what was such does
anybody know
but we were second in the history of all
of television
but the biggest ratings in the history
of cable television it's an honor
last night i did what the corrupt media
has refused to do i held joe biden
accountable for his 47 years
of life 47 years of betrayal
and 47 years of failure i held joe
accountable for shipping your jobs and
dreams abroad
and for bowing to the violent mob at
home can you imagine these people the
way they take over these democrat cities
i don't even believe it
the whole nation saw the truth did you
see last night
name one i said sleepy joe
name one law enforcement group
that supports you and then chris wallace
says don't do that that's not
can you believe this guy i was debating
two people last night
i was debating two people last night joe
biden
is too weak to leave this country you
know biden lost badly when his
supporters are saying he should cancel
the rest of the debates
now i understand he's canceling the
debates let's see what happens i think
that's not going to be a good move
i don't think that's going to be a good
move on television with those ratings
they're never going to let them cancel
you know the television
what are they going to do you know
someday we're not going to be doing this
anymore
what are they going to do without trump
what are they going to know those poor
people look at all of them
whoa that's a lot of people
[Music]
what are they going to do
[Applause]
what are they going to do within 8 12
maybe 16 years i said let's hang it up
looks like
16 more years
[Applause]
but what he's doing is what you do when
you lose so let's see what he does i
don't think he's going to get that
and i've got news for joe if you ever
became president
you have to deal with some of the
toughest people in the world
and chris wallace is very very easy by
comparison i will tell you i know i'm
all
i know them all liberal media is upset
that i took the fight to biden and
exposed this very dangerous agenda
oh there's a beauty here we go here we
go
there's another beauty out there go home
to mom
[Music]
go home these are the same media outlets
cheering violent demonstrations in the
streets cnn
the new york times they think rioting is
just okay just do whatever you want
you can do whatever you want you don't
have to wear a mess you just riot 25 000
people standing on each other's face
do whatever you want can you go to
church no can you go to restaurants no
can you do anything though but you can
riot that's okay
arson's okay but challenging sleepy joe
is totally off limits
uh so disappointed in fox i'm not just
running against joe biden i'm running
against the corrupt far left media
socialists
and communists in the democrat party
and the special interests who've made a
living bleeding our country dry and
that's what's happened for too long
we've turned it around but don't forget
when they turned it around i had to
fight other things like
a fake impeachment i had to fight a lot
of things that are not like that wasn't
in the
agenda never forget and we fought it
very well and frankly we had great
support from the republican party
except for one person but listen we had
great support
never forget they are coming after me
because i am fighting for you and that's
true
[Applause]
and this is a choice election our
opponents put
america last i put america first and
that's what i've been doing for three
and a half years
our opponents want to erase borders i
will defend
our borders you see what's going on in
our southern border by the way
that wall 350 miles already
gonna be finished very soon they don't
talk about the wall anymore fellas
what's going on they don't talk about it
they used to talk about it every day
he's not gonna get his finances
but when you're a real estate developer
you always get financing this was
this was like easy he's not going to get
his financing then we got our finances
they don't talk about it anymore we're
up to
300 almost 360 miles we're drinking
about 10 miles
a week and uh and yeah mexico is paying
for it you do know that right they keep
saying
there's going to be a border charge at
the border for the trucks and cars and
it won't even have to be a lot there's
so many cars and trucks going through
but mexico is paying for it they've been
great they have 27 000 soldiers right
now on our border and we appreciate it
we appreciate the president of mexico
our opponents will send your jobs to
china i will keep your jobs in america
our opponents
want to erase our nation's core values
and i want to defend preserve our
nation's historic values
our opponents stand with rioters i stand
with the heroes of law
[Applause]
enforcement
[Music]
did you see last night i said say the
words to law enforcement don't even say
good or bad
sleepy joe say law enforcement
he goes no i'd rather not say law
enforcement sleepy jail
law enforcement with safety no no no
just law enforcement they tell me that
all the time too please
just say law enforcement with safety
share no it's just
law enforcement it's very simple it's a
very simple term
not with safety unsafety i mean it's law
enforcement he wouldn't say it right
then i said name
one group in the entire nation i've got
minnesota now i've got everybody
name one group in the entire nation
from law enforcement that's supporting
you well well well i'll uh
thank chris wallace okay let's go to the
next question he's in trouble
he's in trouble let me protect him for
fox joe biden says antifa
is just an idea
well ideas don't assault cops and they
don't burn down
buildings antifa is a domestic terrorist
organization
i proudly received the endorsement of
the fraternal order of police
the national association of police
organizations the national troopers
coalition
the international union of police
associations
and law enforcement organizations and
departments in
florida ohio north carolina
colorado arizona nevada wisconsin
pennsylvania
michigan miss minnesota good
[Applause]
i was getting i was getting worried
texas
new york's finest they've never done it
before they came in new york's finest
these are great people they could solve
that problem in two minutes all they
want
is their authority back it's been taken
away from them horribly
new york's finest never endorsed a
candidate for president before and
they're great people
they can do it new jersey illinois and
many many more
i won't bore you but i could go on all
night i just said joe give me one please
he was joking he was i'll tell you he
got saved
joe biden is saying he owns the
socialism
and extremism and his party that he owns
it he it
is you know it's not his party it's not
just sports
that's that you got crazy bernie you
have aoc plus three
you got all these crazy people these
maniacs you have the green new how about
the green new deal he disavowed it
[Music]
and he said no i agree with it i said
you know it's a hundred trillion dollars
that's more money than this country can
make
in the next hundred years if
everything's perfect it's so crisp
it's he wants to rebuild every building
in the village and take it down and
rebuild every building let's say does
that include the empire state but let's
take it down and rebuild
these people are crazy no more cows no
more airplanes no more nothing
biden even vowed to eliminate our tax
cuts
that means you'll take away your child
tax credits
because i gave you child tax cuts
thousand thousand dollars a child
he wants to take away what i gave you
and revoke our historic tax relief
right to the middle class it went joe
biden also refused to answer questions
about packing
the supreme court don't you love the
supreme court i mean how good
how good is amy how good is he
how good is avery
[Music]
you know her professor at notre dame one
of the most highly respected
let's see fill that seat you better
believe it
how good is she so her professor one of
her professors one of the most highly
respected
legal scholars in the country said
been teaching for a long time said she
is the finest singer she was first in
her class graduated first of the class
he said she is the finest student he's
ever had
of all the students thousands of
students she's the single best
student that he's ever had now he's
saying you know she ought to run for
president instead of joe he was like
last in this class
shooter can you imagine this is a big
difference
i don't know how do you like amy for the
supreme court yes
if he gets elected the hard left will
appoint radical justices who will
terminate the second amendment no more
guns
no more good as you all saw biden
also refused to explain why his son
hunter was paid 3.5 billion dollars
protected by chris by the wife of the
former mayor of moscow
and they talk about me with russia i
have nothing to do with russia
and took out 1.5 billion dollars from
china he manages makes millions of
dollars a year right
then he got the 183 right 183
000 a month would anybody like that job
you don't have a job you're not employed
you get thrown out of the military for
unfortunate reasons
your father becomes vice president and
you get hired for 183 thousand dollars a
month
with i think a three million dollar
upfront payment
i think they could have had him for less
would anybody take that job and he knows
nothing about energy what do you know
about energy well that's not my thing no
that's okay
i mean could you imagine if i did it how
about when sleepy joe said
you're not getting the one billion
dollars unless you get rid of the
prosecutor
when you get rid of the prosecutor we'll
send you the money
they got rid of the prosecutor he said
now the money comes i mean can you
imagine if i said that
unbelievable and the press doesn't want
to talk about it and chris wallace said
well we we don't want to discuss that oh
really chris
ah it's so sad i'll tell you it's so
hypocritical so sad this is a matter of
national security and economic security
the bidens got rich while
american workers got robbed how can you
deal with china
if you take out three and a half billion
dollars and make all sorts of money how
can you do it
a critical issue in this election you
saw what i did with china
billions and billions a year they pay us
i gave a lot of it to the farmers 28
billion dollars
[Applause]
a critical issue because they were
targeted by china a critical issue in
this election
is the future of the minnesota iron
range
that's why i'm here this was just
supposed to be a little get together and
then they said sir we've got thousands
of people want to show up i don't know
i don't know how many are involved and
this was supposed to be an iron range
get together
but it turns out big you know biden has
20 30 people they've got those circles
today he had a little bit more like 30
or 40 but they were too
close together cinnamon joe
they were too close 34 people right next
to each other
and yet he complained about our rally
right our rallies
now it's an honor that so many people
showed up because this was going to be a
little quickie just to say
congratulations
because obama closed the iron range and
i opened it
and a man
a man came up to me a tough man a man
who a
worker a construction worker real worker
and he looked at me this is two years
ago he said sir
you've given us back our life and he was
crying
and i said when was the last time you
cried he said i can't remember i said
you never cried when you were a little
baby
you never cried this is not a crier this
guy was tough as hell
he said sir he took our our life away
and let me tell you about joe joe will
reinstitute that ban
in two minutes and we lucy you better
vote for me in minnesota really i mean
honestly
[Applause]
he said you gave you gave our lives back
a lot of lives thousands of jobs
and they closed it up as vice president
joe biden wiped out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he wiped out so much and that includes
what he wiped out
in the great state of minnesota and
we're not going to let it happen anymore
we're not going to let it happen
anymore thousands and thousands of
workers we're not going to let it happen
anymore they were all laid off and now
they're all back
and by the way they say what the hell do
i know about iron ore
but i've put a lot of steel and a lot of
iron over the years
but you know they say it's the greatest
iron ore anywhere in the world
and you should have it after i put
tariffs on foreign steel
the iron rage came roaring back but the
biggest thing i did was knock out his
executive order
i've knocked out so much of the things
that he did
he can't can't like me too much i would
say he doesn't like me too much hey did
you see what happened with the fbi
they caught them cold comey either has
the worst memory in history did you
i don't remember that did you spy on
president trump's campaign i don't
remember that
did you go for a coup
did you go for a coup uh i don't i don't
remember i don't know
i'll tell you we caught them cold it's
about time that something
happens okay it's about time that
something happens it's enough
we got plenty of information of these
crooks a bunch of crooks
thing like that's never happened in the
history of our country and it's about
time that something happens
we rescinded the federal withdrawal
in superior national forest you all know
all about that
you people especially to restore mineral
exploration for the iron ore miners in
minnesota
well we've done for minnesota i lose
minnesota i'm never coming back i don't
care
i'm never coming back we protected iron
range workers
from frivolous lawsuits that was a big
deal right the frivolous lawsuits we
started construction on the soo lock
to get iron ore to market very quickly
so not only did we open it we get it to
market
we fixed the locks because you couldn't
even get it out those things were so old
and broke and now they're
going to be very shortly in perfect
shape i opened up
permitting for copper nickel mining
anybody involved there oh
it sounded a little far out but a lot of
people doing that
and i strongly support the replacement
of the decaying
line three pipeline we're going to
replace it it's all done
it's all done all of this is why
nine democrat mayors of cities in the
iron range
have endorsed me over sleepy joe biden
are they here i don't know if they're
here tonight
these people are fantastic look at these
great congressmen where are they
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
we had a ceremony a month ago where i
introduced every one of them you know
i'm not introducing you again it's
freezing out here
but i want to thank you you're great
people great mayors and
i appreciate the support very much these
are democrats that voted for
i want to vote for trump that endorsed
me fully we've done a good job over
there everything in good shape right
good thank you very much it's a great
honor
if joe gets in the radical left will
shut down
the iron range forever it's going to be
gone they're not going to be able to
open it again not easy
to open a thing like that not easy a lot
more difficult than people would think
earlier today
i took another historic step for your
state when i signed an executive order
provided billions of dollars to jump
start production of critical
and other minerals which will create
countless jobs and are so important
for our country minerals
[Applause]
i will always protect the state of
minnesota i will do that it's been very
good to me
we almost want it we almost want it one
more speech
i had a choice do i do michigan which we
won
do i do i should have done them both
one more speech we lost by very little
think of that though has it been won by
a republican i don't get that because
the democrats have done such a lousy
pathetic job
hasn't been won since 1972.
reagan lost it it was the only steady
loss remember so we're going to change
that we've got to change it
who's going to do what we've done for
you
right another massive issue for
minnesota is the election
of joe biden's plan to inundate your
state with a historic
flood of refugees
[Applause]
[Music]
biden and crazy bernie sanders have
agreed on a manifesto did you see last
night i didn't agree i didn't agree
after the show they said oh actually he
did oh great they fact checked
they found out he made a mistake slight
mistake it's the worst thing you've ever
seen
but they pledged a 700 increase in
refugees
700 percent congratulations minnesota
congratulations now and what about
omar where she gets caught harvesting
what the hell is going on i hope your us
attorney is involved
what what is going on with omar i've
been reading these reports for two years
about how corrupt and crooked she is
let's get with it let's get with it
i mean frankly harvesting's terrible but
it's the least of the things that she
has done
how to help then she tells us how to run
our country can you believe it
how the hell did minnesota elect her
what the hell is wrong with you people
right what the hell happened
these guys in the stand up are you are
you a big fan of omar i don't think so
stand up look at this guy he looks like
nobody's going to fight him i don't
think you're a big fan of omar right
no she's been crooked for a long time
this is the least seven
it's time and you know what aoc also
it's time
it's time you take a look at what the
corruption the disgusting corruption
700 increase refugees coming from the
most dangerous places in the world
including yemen
syria and your favorite country somalia
right you love casamagi
this guy loves somalia mine will turn
minnesota into a refugee camp and he
said that
overwhelming public resources
overcrowding schools
and inundating your hospitals you know
that it's already there to disgrace what
they've done to you
it's just it's absolutely it's a
disgrace okay
biden has even pledged to terminate our
travel ban
on jihadist regions opening the
floodgates to radical
islamic terrorism remember i used to
talk about it all the time i got a band
remember they said you'd never be able
to get a band
and then i lost at the lower court i
lost at the court of appeals
and they said he lost he lost in
houston's that i wanted the supreme
court they didn't even report it
and they still say he lost on the travel
ban he lost he lost
but they are talking about the first two
courts they forget to say that at the
supreme court
these are the most dishonest it's hard
to believe actually but look at all
those cameras it's a lot
they love it i love every time i'm
getting ready you know they've gotten
very good at this every time i'm getting
ready to hit them the lights just go off
you know those red lights
my administration is keeping terrorist
extremists and criminals out of our
country
and we're keeping them the hell out of
minnesota
[Applause]
and we've ended the refugee influx into
your state you were one of the
most hard-hit states for whatever reason
we've ended it you know that right you
know that does anybody know this
does anybody know this i don't think
they tell you about it but you know they
talk about
the suburbs women in the suburbs i ended
a regulation
that nobody would have done this brings
public housing low-income housing into
the suburbs and by the way just so we
can get this right
30 of the people in the suburbs
are low-income people 30 of the people
in the suburbs are minorities
and so we're ruining this american dream
for everybody but he's got
a plan it's the worst thing you've ever
seen having to do with zoning
they zone you out they build low income
housing next to your house
it's crazy and then i hear i'm not doing
well in the suburbs
i'm not doing well in the suburbs are
you people crazy
are you crazy i just explained this no i
just explained
thank you no it's crazy and they came to
me
great people ben carson a lot of great
people and they came to me and they said
sir why don't we just amend it
i said no really i want it out i want it
over i want it ended
well it'd be a lot easier to amend it i
said nope i want it over it's not right
it's killing your suburbs and it is it's
killing your subways and then they say
women in the suburbs don't like
president trump i don't think so that
happened last summer
remember that happened remember last
time
they said he will not do well with women
he will not do well with him
[Applause]
he will not do well with women these
were the idiots
on election night four years ago he will
not do this will be a very short night
for donald trump at the time
this will be a very short then at the
end they said he did really well with
women it was sort of weird
anyway we did well with everybody
actually and we're going to do even
better now we have more
enthusiasm look at this crowd this was
supposed to be a few people
this was supposed to be this was
supposed to be just a little celebration
i said oh good a little celebration i
figured a couple of hundred people like
sleepy joe gets in his best day
i said how many people about ten
thousand sarah said
in just three and a half years we've
secured america's border rebuilt
awesome power of the u.s military
obliterated the isis caliphate
fixed our disastrous trade deals and
they were a disaster
and brought jobs back home to america
and back home
to minnesota we brought a lot of jobs
back
[Applause]
last year before the play came in from
china you had the best year you've ever
had
the year before that you had the best
year you've ever had until the following
year
and we're doing it again we're building
it up rapidly china came up they gave us
the plague it's no good
we're never going to forget that i did a
trade deal the ink wasn't even dry
and they let that happen we're never
going to forget it we built
the greatest economy in the history of
the world and now we are quickly doing
it again
we've added a historic 10.6 million jobs
in the last four months
that's a record the likes of which has
never even been
close to being challenged
[Music]
to fight the china virus we launched the
largest national mobilization since
world war ii
we pioneered life-saving therapies
reducing the fatality rate 85
since april think of that meaning you go
to the hospital
and you got a lot better chance i'll
tell you what i spoke to
a gentleman today from pfizer i speak to
all of these guys these are great people
and they're coming up with things that
are phenomenal regenerate
we are coming up with things that are
phenomenal including
therapeutics with therapies it's
incredible what's happening you'll be
seeing it
you'll be seeing it very and by the way
with biden it would have been years
before you came up with any of this
years it would have been years he
complains you didn't knock fast enough
and yet he's all over the place calling
me xenophobic because i closed the
border okay how do you figure that one
this guy just a politician he's just
another politician 47 years he hasn't
done a damn thing
but now he's gone but now he's going to
i haven't done anything in 47 years but
now i'm going to
europe is almost a 50 greater excess
mortality rate than the united states
you don't hear that
through operation warp speed we will
develop and distribute
a vaccine in record time it's going to
be very very soon
and before the end of the year maybe
sooner than that on november 3rd
minnesota will decide whether
we end this pandemic defeat the virus
and return to record prosperity either
way we're returning
either way we're going to have the
vaccine
we're rounding the turn well whether we
allow joe biden to kill the recovery you
know he wants to shut down this guy says
let's shut it down
a lot of death caused by shut down
depression
death drugs alcoholism
horrendous family fights horrendous
family fuzz
and he wants to destroy those suburbs by
abolishing
single-family zoning all of these things
are just a horrible thing
what he wants to do and i think he's
going to do it because he's not smart
enough to understand that
the other side has big problems you know
we did something great with the greatest
economy in history
and we had to close it down because we
lost millions of lives
and now we're opening it up and we're
doing it at a level like nobody's ever
seen before and it's a great thing
and we're going to be back in business
very soon except for some democrats
and they'll all open up they're going to
all open up right after
november 3rd they'll announce we'd like
to uh tell you that we're all opening up
november 4th
did you see the one group they said
we're opening up yeah right after the
election i think we'll open oh that's
great
these are terrible people because
they're more interested in politics than
they
are in the lives of people they want to
confiscate your guns
and indoctrinate your children there's
poisonous anti
rhetoric and lies to combat
the toxic left when you see this that
toxic
left-wing propaganda in our schools we
are launching a new pro-american lesson
plan for students called the 1776
commission
we will teach our children the truth
about america that we are the most
exceptional nation on the face of the
earth that's what i want them to hear
we are joined tonight by some real
warriors friends of mine they fight with
they take they they just win they know
how to win i'm telling you you have some
great ones
and they really are they're great people
the impeachment hoax they fought it's so
great these are real warriors i call
them warriors representatives
tom emmer
[Applause]
jim hagedorn
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and i'll tell you we have some
incredible congressional candidates that
we're going to work because we've got to
get nancy pelosi the hell out of there
and we're very proud
we have some candidates tyler christner
where's tyler
where's david thank you tyler great job
i hear great things tyler
a man with the greatest name in politics
lacey johnson
great guy great guy
and somebody is going to help us a lot
along with tyler
lacey michelle fishbach thank you
michelle
we're going to be working with you and
they all have my total endorsement you
know that okay
the next u.s senator from minnesota is a
man who was born for this position
unlike your current senator who nobody
knows who the hell she is
who is she i said who is she is she in
the senate
jason lewis
[Music]
thank you jason great job you're doing
that we got to get jason in got to get
them all in
rnc co-chairman tommy hicks tommy hicks
thank you tommy
and mike lindell he makes more pillows
this guy
[Applause]
thank you mike he goes to a lot of my
rallies he likes israel and we like him
here as well tonight is 96 year old
world war ii veteran
dr john rings ready
whoa look at you whoa
you look great john wow
you look good handsome thank you john
thank you very much it's an honor john
after years of rebuilding other nations
we are finally rebuilding our nation
in 2017 i signed a very historic
executive order making it difficult
and really just looking at what
government policy has to
do in order to buy american and hire
can you ever see biden he's got to sign
buy a merchant i said he got it from me
i've been doing
this for a long time copies my campaign
copies our
plans these copies a lot you haven't
heard that before
he invested 2.5 trillion dollars in the
military we put 2.5 trillion in
we have the best weapons all made in the
usa we have the greatest weaponry we've
ever had no country no country has ever
come close to the kind of firepower we
have
hopefully hope to god we never have to
use it
we have firepower and weapons and the
republicans did it because the democrats
so we have to have that
otherwise we're going to be at the mercy
of other countries we have the greatest
firepower the greatest weapons
in the history of the world hope to god
that we never have to use them
and we launched a new branch
of the u.s armed forces first since
the air force in 75 years it's called
the space force
that's a big deal we killed the founder
and leader of isis al-baghdadi
gone
we took out the world's number one
terrorist and the murder
of so many american troops and plenty of
other troops
kasim salamani is no longer with us
i withdrew from the last
administration's
total disaster the iran nuclear deal
okay obama gave him 150 billion
that was bad but he gave 1.8 billion in
cash how the hell do you do that
what does 1.8 billion in cash look like
they must have looked at that they said
man
plane loads of cash i kept my promise
recognized the true capital of israel
and opened the american embassy in
jerusalem
i also recognized israeli sovereignty
over the golan heights and instead of
endless wars we are forging peace in the
middle east
[Applause]
and i was nominated for three nobel
prizes and not one
i didn't get one story i didn't get one
so
i have to tell you because they refused
to ride it when obama got his
nobel prize they didn't i mean it was
the biggest story i've ever seen right
and he didn't even know why he got it he
got it like immediately upon taking
office what a difference
but i told my first lady i told her
first lady
darling you're going to be so proud of
me tonight we're going to watch
television
and you're not going to believe how big
this goes what happened what happened
darling i won the i was nominated for
the
nobel peace prize for israel right
bahrain united arab emirates
and then again again
i was nominated again for serbia kosovo
all different and i was nominated the
third time but i said first time
second time i was a little bit yeah i
know i love you too
when i said to our first lady watch
this tonight darling it's going to be
and i turned to lester holt number two
show
i turned to lester hall and they covered
one stories about rain
another was about the environment
another was about
something else another was a bad hit on
me
another was something else so now we're
through with about half of it now they
went to the longest commercial i've ever
seen
not supposed to you know when you report
the fake news you're not supposed to get
free airtime from the us government
does anybody know what that means and
then they went on to the second half
again and again and again she looked at
me darling i don't think they're gonna
cover this i said
it's impossible it's a nomination
for the nobel peace award it's
impossible guess what it ended we got
nothing
then three days later we got nothing and
on the third time
the third time i said let's not even
watch we're not gonna get it
these people are sick but i did more in
47 months than sleepy joe biden did in
47 years
[Applause]
and now he's pushing the most far left
platform in history
the biden plan would destroy social
security and destroy protections for
people with pre-existing conditions
give free federal health care to all
illegal aliens
bankrupting medicare well you know
what's going to happen they're going to
pour into our country when you hear that
they're going to come in
they're very smart very sophisticated
you'd be surprised band school choice
and ban all charter schools no more
charter schools no more school choice
well we're making a lot of progress
in the second term i will provide school
choice to every parent in america
a vote for republicans is a vote for
safe communities
great jobs and a limitless future for
all americans
and in conclusion over the next four
years we will make america into the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for all did you see what he
said last night
about manufacturer obama said we're not
going to ever have manufacturing and you
need a magic wand last night you said
we're doing manufacturing no no
they gave up in manufacturing i had
almost 700 000
manufacturing jobs i said how can you
lose
these bad news they lie we will make our
medical supplies right here in the
united states
we will hire more police increased
penalties on assaults
[Applause]
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
we will uphold religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear arms
second behind
we will strike down terrorists who
threaten our citizens
and we will keep out we will keep people
out of our country
thank you
[Music]
but we will keep out of these ridiculous
endless wars in countries that you've
never heard of and you never will hear
of it's ridiculous
and we're bringing them all home you see
that we will maintain
america's unrivaled military might and
we will ensure peace
through strength that's what we have
ridiculous we're all over the world
we're in places nobody ever heard of
before
we will end surprise medical billing
require price
transparency i've already signed it can
you believe it kicks in on january 1st
can you imagine if this clown gets in
and they'll say you got price
transparency what's that that'll have
such an impact it kicks in i said to my
people you think you could have kicked
it in a little bit earlier
i'd further reduce health insurance
premiums and the cost of
prescription drugs which we're going to
be bringing down massively because of
favored nations
we will strongly protect medicare and
social security and we will always
protect
those incredible people as i said with
pre-existing conditions
america will land the first woman on the
moon and the united states will be the
first nation to land an
astronaut on mars and it will be soon
you have to see nasa has become again
the greatest
space center in the world you had to see
what it looked like when i took over it
was terrible
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students
and restore patriotic education to our
schools
we will teach our children to love our
country honor our history
and always respect our great american
flag
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national
motto in god we trust
[Music]
for years you had a president who
apologized for america now you have a
president
who is standing up for america and
standing up
for the great people of minnesota thank
you
[Applause]
but if we don't win i'm never calling
you great again
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors
and get your co-workers and get out and
vote we gotta win
we gotta win
early voting has already begun don't
wait please go out and vote
did you see in new york today a hundred
thousand fraudulent ballots
they sent out a hundred thousand ballots
wrong names wrong addresses wrong
envelopes other than that they did quite
well
thank you in a hundred thousand so you
know what their solution that's okay
we'll send out another hundred thousand
i said
really what's gonna happen to the first
hundred thousand who's gonna vote them
this is crazy what's going on this is
crazy
from saint paul to saint cloud
from minneapolis to minnetonka
and from rochester to right here in
duluth i like to live
this great day was pioneered by men and
women
who braved the wilderness and the
winters to build a better life
for themselves and for their families
they were truly brave
brilliant incredible people they were
tough
and they were strong they didn't have a
lot of money
they didn't have a lot of luxury but
they had grit
they had faith and they had each other
[Applause]
they were miners and lumberjacks
fishermen and farmers ship builders and
shopkeepers
but they all had one thing in common
they loved their families they loved
their country
and they loved their god
[Music]
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country
we are returning power to you
the american people with your help
your devotion and your drive we are
going to
keep on working we are going to keep on
fighting and we are going to keep on
winning winning winning
[Applause]
it's true it's we're going to keep on
winning you know minnesota maybe i'll
just do it real soon because we need
jason jason
jason's going to come jason lewis going
to be your senator
you're going to win so much you know
that one right you've heard you should
do it or not
beautiful crescendo of a speech and now
i have to ruin it with the story with
jason but let's do it anyway but we're
going to win so much
because minnesota before i came around
was not doing too well
okay i was not doing too well then you
had your best years ever
but we're going to win so much and
you're going to go and see your great
senator
jason lewis he's going to say and you're
going to see emma
and you're going to see all of it and
you're going to say mr senator please go
see the president
we're winning too much we can't stand it
sir
minnesota we're not used to winning this
much it's too much sir
please go see well i don't want to do
that please senator go see
the president we're winning too much we
cannot stand it
for years we've done poorly before he
came along now we're doing so well
and we're growing now stronger than ever
before we don't want to win so much mr
senator
so your senator's going to come in hi
jason how you doing sir
minnesota's winning too much we have to
stop it
i said what are you talking about sir we
have to stop but it's just too much
winning we have to stop it
i say jason let me tell you i know the
people of
minnesota and they love winning they're
going to keep winning
we're going to win we're going to win so
much we're going to keep forward winning
and you're going to have the greatest
year that you've ever had next year
and the year after and that's where it's
heading so i just want to thank you and
jason
i'm sorry i will not follow your wish
thank you very much but we're we are
we're one movement
we're one family we're one beautiful
people and one glorious nation under god
and together with the incredible people
of minnesota
we will make america wealthy again we
will make
america strong again we will make
america proud again we will
make america safe again
and we will make america great again
thank you minnesota gardens
[Music]
so
[Music]
there's no need to feel down
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
you can make
[Music]
all by himself
mca i'm sure
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
ymca they can't stop
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
now
[Music]
wow
listen to me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
music man
[Music]
valerina you must have seen
her dancing in
now she's in me
with me a tiny dancing
in my hand
jesus freaks
out industry
handing tickets out for gone
[Music]
is not that bad
[Music]
in their auditorium
[Music]
knows
[Music]
i feel sorry lying here
with no one near only you
and you can't hear me
when i say softly
[Music]
slowly
[Music]
on the highway
[Music]
dance
[Music]
[Music]
today
[Music]
blue
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
you marry a music man
[Music]
now she's in me
in my head
[Music]
when i say softly
slowly
[Music]
on the highway
[Music]
and now the end is near
and so i face
the final curtain
my friend i'll say it here
i have which i am
[Music]
[Music]
and every highway
much more than this
[Music]
i did what i
had to do
saw it without
exception i
found each chart of course
each cat will step
[Music]
along the byway
and more much
more than this i did it
my way